Hello, I'm Sara Zaman with VOA 60 America for May 15th.
President Barack Obama and First Lady Michelle Obama...
...joined family members, survivors and rescuers...
...for the dedication of the National September 11 Memorial Museum...
...ahead of next week's public opening.
The museum has been years in the making.
It contains parts of the World Trade Center towers...
...and nearly 2,000 oral histories and personal items that belong to the victims.
Wildfires continue to rage in Southern California...
...after thousands of people were forced to evacuate their homes.
Governor Jerry Brown has declared a state of emergency...
...to bring more resources in to fight the fires.
And finally, at least fifty thousand gallons of oil...
...have spilled onto the streets of Los Angeles.
A 20-inch pipe developed a leak, spewing oil that is knee-deep in some areas.
Workers are trying to contain the spill before it seeps into sewers and storm drains...
...and pollutes groundwater.
That's all for today, thanks for watching.